dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on I say here this
paper is about designing and creating
furniture with pieces that are
geometrically interlocked such pieces
not only have artistic value but such
structures can also enhance the
integrity and sturdiness of the piece of
furniture this piece of work takes a
simple 2d drawing of this interlocking
structure and assembles the required
pieces for us to build the 3d model from
them this drawing can be done with one
of the most user-friendly modular
program out there Google Sketchup this
can be used even by novices from these
disassembled parts it is highly
non-trivial to create a 3d printable
model for instance it is required that
these pieces can be put together with
one translational motion basically all
we need is one nudge to put two of these
pieces together if you ever had a new
really simple piece of furniture from
Ikea have a look at the final product at
the shop and thought well I only have
ten minutes to put this thing together
but anyway how hard can it be and you
know three hours of cursing later the
damn thing is still not completely
assembled if you have any of those
experiences before this one push
assembly condition is for you and the
algorithm automatically finds a sequence
of motions that assembles our target 3d
shape and because we only have two the
information from the input it also has
to decide how and where to extrude
thicken or subtract from these volumes
the third space of possible motions is
immense and we have to take into
consideration that we don't even know if
there is a possible solution for this
puzzle at all if this is the case the
algorithm finds out and proposes changes
to the model that make the construction
feasible and if this wasn't enough we
can also put this digital furniture
model into a virtual world where
gravitational forces are simulated to
see how stable the final result is here
the proposed yellow regions indicate
that the stability of this table could
be improved via small modifications it
is remarkable to see that a novice user
who has never done a minute of 3d
modeling can create such a beautiful and
resilient piece of furniture
really
nice work loving it thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]